era 16 de septiembre de 1982 no
refugiada Palestina sabra y shatila
tenía 13 años y el destino le regaló una
segunda oportunidad
sobrevivió a una masacre Gracias a que
se ocultó bajo los cuerpos de sus
familiares ejecutados por milicianos
falangistas cristianos
del mundo donde estaban entonces las
fuerzas internacionales de Estados
Unidos Francia Italia y Reino Unido los
ejércitos árabes El Nacional libanés que
nadie pudo protegernos
la masacre le dejó un trauma duradero
pero al mismo tiempo le da fuerzas para
seguir con la esperanza de que algún día
los responsables de estos crímenes
rindan cuentas Un año más en estas
fechas nohad y su hermano Mohamed junta
cientos de palestinos marchan por las
callejuelas que fueron testigos de las
ejecuciones masivas para seguir
reclamando justicia después de la
masacre Mohamed y otro sobrevivientes
abrieron un caso contra el ex Primer
Ministro israelí Ariel Sharon en un
tribunal de Bélgica pero años después
las autoridades belgas prohibieron el
acto de mandar a presidentes y generales
fue muy triste para nosotros nos rompió
el corazón por lo que pedimos a la Corte
Internacional de Justicia que persuada
al sistema judicial belga para que
continúe con el caso y Luche con
nosotros por nuestros derechos Como
refugiados a pesar de que ya han pasado
tres generaciones en los campamentos los
refugiados que se abre shatila no se
sienten Bienvenidos en el Líbano desde
hace 75 años nos han prometido que
regresaremos a nuestra patria somos
palestinos y ya sea que tengamos que
vivir oprimidos y con miedo a que nos
masacren nunca olvidaremos nuestra
patria queremos volver en paz la masacre
de más de 3000 palestinos
más oscuros de la guerra civil libanesa
y pone de manifiesto la difícil
convivencia a los refugiados palestinos
pesegnaciones unidas lo califica de
genocidio este AC ta trot sigue siendo
un pune 40 años después